Lay's by Sasha Bullock Nelson we talking
about connection to insanity
thanks for the introduction here my name
is Sasha gloomy off and today I would
like to talk about connections between
data sexual are bonds and circuit lower
bounds on Magic City genes and this is
based on a joint work where is ZF de
Vere from Princeton and Omri weinstein
from columbia so i will first define
static data structures that were working
with so yeah we're going to be working
over an arbitrary field f for simplicity
you can think that this sexual and in a
data structure problem we have n inputs
and outputs and typically m is a
polynomial of n and when i ask you to
solve a static data structure problem
and basically asking you to come up with
two functions one is pre-processing
function it takes all the n inputs and
outputs some number s of memory cells
and the other function is query function
it will be just answering my m output
queries so it takes whatever you pre
computed in the first step and outputs
all the all the query query values and
since you don't want to lose input
information s is usually greater than n
for any non-trivial function you need at
least and cells to store the thing so
pictorially it looks like like this you
have basically adapts to the circuit you
have n inputs you reprocess them into a
larger number of cells yes and then you
want to be correct on all m outputs and
M is huge it's I know n to the hundred
there are two parameters who care about
one space how much space you store to
answer all my queries and we denoted by
s and the other one is T it it kind of
time you spend for for each output but
by the time here we only mean how many
cells you read so there are two
important parameters as space T tea time
this mixer
okay so and every data structure problem
has two trivial solutions one is when
you store answers for all output queries
you spent a lot of memory or spent M
cells of space but then query time is
trivial just one the other the other
trivial solution for every data
structure problem is when you store only
input but then for every non-trivial
problem you have to spend a lot of time
spend time and because output might
depend on all the input yeah and yeah
it's static data data structure problem
in the very beginning I'm telling you
I'm going to be asking this M questions
please answer them correctly on every
single input yeah so and as always
random data structure problem super hard
it requires space almost m and time
almost n but again as always we want to
find an explicit function which is hard
for data structures and the best what we
know is Larsson 2012 it's T must be at
least log M over log s over N which let
me parse it for you when s is linear
when when you want to store on the
linear space there we know that T must
be at least logarithmic and when s is
polynomially super linear then we know
nothing we only know the team has the
super constant constant yeah yeah yeah
it was reproved like four times yeah
yeah the first time it was brought in
late 70s I guess basically yeah okay and
[Music]
okay so this is our setup here and
yeah and so one can think about data
structure is a depth to circuit and in
this work won't understand connections
to a circuit lower bounds or matrix' TG
so let me define you what I mean by
circuit like like it is already more or
less defined or what I need so in the
circuit world we normally work with an
inputs and linear number of outputs not
necessarily but it's usually the case
and here by circuit I mean such a
defined directed acyclic graph where
funding of each gate is two we want to
prove my deal is super polynomial
circuit lower bound so at least super
linear best what we can do is roughly
three and a five and depending on how
you define circuits and as we usually do
in such a case we just say okay let us
try to solve a special case so the
problem was solved a bunch of special
cases in the 80s and we seem to have a
hard special case hard special case
which we cannot solve is when we
restrict the depths for example if we
restrict the depths to be say half log
and then since funniness two of every
gate your output does not depend even on
the whole input so every non-trivial
function cannot be computed by such a
circuit but we also know functions which
cannot be computed by circuits of depth
1.9 log N or 2.9 log n depends on again
how you define circuits but this is kind
of chitin because it's not like we're
proving super linear lower bounds for
for the circuits we're just saying these
depths is not sufficient to compute our
functions we don't know how to use depth
restriction in our circuit lower bounds
except for one thing in 1977 Whalen said
that here is a way which can possibly
help us we yeah of using depth
restriction so the result is based on
the beautiful work of our - Greg
handsome LED and sasha showed it like
it's been 40 years since when improved
it so we know many ways to present
valiance result such as showed it what
it means in terms of depth researchers
but I want to make it more similar to
data structure setting so I'll present
variants result in the language of lips
to circuit it says the fuller and you
have n inputs M outputs and you pre
compute just a little of information
epsilon n actually you can make it n
over log log n much smaller than in the
case of the data structures and clearly
this is not sufficient to compute all
outputs so you have to allow outputs to
depend on inputs as well so but the time
it they depend only a tiny bit each
output can only see n to the epsilon
bits of information so what well
improved is that if you can prove a
lower bound against this model then you
immediately get a super linear lower
bound followed a log depth circuit and
the goal of this will be basically when
I say that these two pictures look
similar the one for data structures and
the one for lock depth circuits and
actually in the case when all functions
data structures and circuits are linear
we proved that the Zi equivalent in some
sense so yeah we have to restrict our
attention to the linear case we say that
so I assume that all AM output functions
are linear functions of the input just
some linear combinations of the inputs
and whatever you compute here and here
is also linear actually it was shown by
ukemi' and snooger that it suffices to
assume that only this layer is linear
then without loss of generality without
any loss of the parameters you can make
the middle layer linear as well
so while working with linear functions
now and then the result of valiant can
be state as follows say you want to
compute circuit which computes
multiplication by a matrix M that is it
takes a vector X F to the N and it
outputs n times X then any circuit of
linear size and logarithmic depth which
computes such a linear map just from
this can be written as the following
some a very sparse matrix a
which corresponds to dependence of the
outputs on the inputs plus product of
two matrices one is this sparse
transformation and the other one is
whatever you computed the middle layer
so it's the sum of sparse matrix plus a
product of two matrices we can forget
for a second that see sparse later on if
time permits I will show you that it
might be useful to to actually remember
that see sparse but for now let's forget
and then we can just write it as a sum
of a sparse matrix and matrix of small
rank it has small rim just because it's
a product of two matrices of small
dimension and this at least the
definition of rigidity I will say that
matrix is say epsilon n comma T rigid if
it cannot be written as a sum of C
sparse matrix and a matrix of fluorine
by its his parts matrix I always mean a
matrix which has at most C nonzero
elements in every row my sparsity will
be always I'm going to be talking about
rectangular matrices and sparsity always
means the number of nonzero elements per
row and yeah and basically if you find
the rigid matrix which is for rank
epsilon and it requires and to the Delta
for arbitrary constants epsilon and
Delta rigidity then that's it you prove
a super linear lower bound in this
setting but the best what we can do is
far from our from this for example
forked for square matrices we can only
get constant rigidity here and Allan
panagra he an Iranian showed that if you
consider rectangular matrices of size
poly n by n then you can do slightly
better then you can do log N
okay and now for a second let's return
to the data structure to the data
structure question absol if if you don't
mind having sub-linear wrong then we
know better
yeah we'll get to this later hope for
them yeah so let's get back to the data
structure question here we also want to
consider linear functions that is all
our M outputs a linear functions and you
only compute linear functions here then
whatever compute here can also be
written like you compute for every input
X you compute n times X where M can be
written as follows
this is whatever your whatever your
output layer computes some matrix a
times matrix B which corresponds to
whatever computing the middle layer and
a is T sparse
because each of your outputs depends
only on C elements and be small so M is
of size n rows of size M times your
space and B is s times so if you want to
find a problem which is hard for linear
data structures just find the matrix
which doesn't have such a decomposition
and what we're saying this work is just
this decomposition in data structures
and the one in rigidity they are related
ok so I've given like enough definitions
let me show you an example of connection
between data structures and rigidity and
if you like it then I will give two
final definitions from which we can just
collect all the results about how how
equivalent to GCC and data structures
are so let me show you an example of
such a connection so I want to say is it
clear any questions ok so if you have a
matrix in or we need to take
matrix of anhydrous honest oh it's
n-by-n matrix with and SS okay so other
questions
woman approves the following lemma save
half a matrix which is not rigid which
is not rigid for an epsilon N and some
parameter sparsity T then we'll show
that there exists a matrix of the same
size such that its column space
intersects a lot the column space of M
it spends almost all column space of a
matrix M constant fraction and that's it
that's easy to show I assume M is not
rigid so there is a decomposition as
force M asam of sparse and low rank now
let me define a linear map such that
it's kernel is exactly the column space
of M I can always easily do this I just
say I take any basis of M say that you
output 0 on this basis and then I extend
this basis to the basis of the whole
space and say your identity there
extended by linearity so it's easy to
construct such a thing hello whose karma
was exactly a column space of this now
let me apply this L to this equation L
times M is L times a plus L times B but
L times M is 0 because I defined else's
way so L times a equals minus L times B
in particular rank of a lay is rank of
LD but B is a low rank matrix so even
when I apply the transfer linear map L
it's still around on the other hand
the rank of Ace is large for example is
the sum of I can always without loss of
generality assume that M is full rank
matrix otherwise it's even easier for me
so M is the sum of matrices like full
rank and low rank so it's rank must be
must be large and how can it happen that
you apply this transformation to matrix
of rank almost N and get matrix of rank
almost nothing
this means that the kernel of L
intersects the column space of a but
kernel of a is exactly the column space
of M so this means that intersection of
column space of a and M is huge it's
almost n it reduces it from almost end
to almost nothing
and a is a sparse matrix I just found a
sparse matrix which spans almost all
column space of your not rigid matrix
yeah I want any which is sure sure I'm
sorry I meant to say that a is part of
us yeah otherwise it doesn't make sense
yeah I always can find sparse matrix
which generates almost all my own space
and this force matrix is exactly the
matrix you give me in reduces in the
composition yeah and now let me prove
that a data structure lower bound
implies some rigidity we can prove
stronger results later but let me show
you a result of this form fix see like
what don't fix see for every magic stem
it's either computable by a data
structure with linear space like really
small inner space and time T or it
contains a rigid sub matrix it gets like
a good it has a good rank parameter and
it also it loses the only logarithmic
factor in the in the
in particular if you give me matrix
which cannot be computed by a data
structure then it contains a rigid sub
matrix moreover this can be made
explicit this matrix M prime belongs to
reasonable complexity class to a
complexity class where we wanna prove
for rigidity of circuit lower bounds and
how do we prove this theorem now it's
easier does the statement make sense if
you give me a matrix which cannot be
computed by a data structure then it
contains three digits so here's the
matrix and I'm just going to be used
recursively using this lemma to prove
the theorem so I look at the matrix who
gave me an by n matrix if it's already
rigid I'm done I proved that it's rigid
otherwise I know that if it's not rigid
then there is a sparse matrix which
generates a huge chunk of the columns
let me call this M Prime
I know that M prime is some product of
the matrix a times B where is this part
just a previous same we know that a
times B where a sparse is exactly the
data structure so I have a data
structure which
correctly computes every single output
on these inputs except for some fraction
of the inputs so now I just recursively
apply the same procedure to to the
remaining inputs I'm saying ok let's
look at this matrix if you three it I'm
done I proved that it contains a rigid
sub matrix otherwise I come up with a
data structure for this input and I
repeated just like Logan times in the
end I have a tiny matrix which I can
solve by a trivial data structure so
either my algorithm at some at some
steps is a rigid matrix which I'm happy
about
oh I construct a an efficient data
structure which I'm also happy about
good
ok then I'll just give two definitions
and they basically set the stage for all
our results and all the results are
following just like one line each
let them be matrix of size M by n and
see some sparsity parameter then we
define but this is a recall is s but we
put like dimensions they were defined by
petunia mood like in 2006 we just use
like a different form of them yes they
define it for columns and with for some
reason it it for us and it seems
important for some reason here yeah so
give me a matrix then outer dimension of
this matrix matrix for the sparsity
parameter t is the minimum width of a
matrix of a sparse matrix whose columns
space contains the column space of your
matrix
what's the smallest width of a sparse
matrix which contains your matrix and
the inner dimension is kind of the
opposite its you give me a matrix and
I'm looking at all sparse matrices of
the same size what is the largest
dimension of the column space
intersections and
it's not hard to show that actually
outer dimension exactly corresponds to
data structure complexity of the problem
problem can be solved by st data
structure if and only if the outer
dimension was sparse the parameter C is
at most s the inner dimension exactly
corresponds to a stronger version of
rigidity matrix is strongly rigid if and
only if it has small inner dimension and
after this all what we are doing we just
proven like tight inequalities between
inner and outer dimensions and they give
us the correspondence between rigidity
and data structural error bounds in both
directions so the theorem which we just
proved basically says that if your
matrix has large outer outer dimension
then it contains a sub matrix with small
inner dimension
Sparty parameter slightly smaller and
this implies that if you have a data
structure lower bound like for any for
any query time T and space n times 1
plus epsilon then you have for example a
rectangular rigid matrix with a
parameter like better than we know
moreover we can stake this rectangular
matrices together and get a square
matrix with a rigidity parameter better
than we know so any improvement on the
current data structure lower bound would
imply non-trivial result in matrix ng
the same we can also do there is a like
one-line proof of the phone and call it
C whatever whatever matrix you consider
as some of its inner and outer
dimensions is at least 2 n and as again
the rank of the matrix dimension of the
matrix this implies for example that if
you have a rigid matrix then you have
like in the other direction then you
have a data structure lower bound
indeed read rigid matrix means your
inner their dimension is small this
inequality says that if your inner
dimension small then outer dimension is
large and outer dimension is exactly the
data structure complex so we have the
correspondence in the other direction as
well and we can do other things for
example if you have very strong data
structure lower bound for example if for
linear number of outputs you have
the structure lower bound of n times 1
plus epsilon for the query time n to the
epsilon then you also get a super linear
circuit lower bound for this you just
need to show that that that Valiant
result it says that every small circuit
gives you the following decomposition
where a and B as parts both both of them
and if you keep in mind that both of
them are sparse then you can see that
actually this means that the column
space of M is generated by the column
spaces of a and B which is which exactly
matches the definition of outer
dimension this says that every MAGIX are
computed by a log depth circuit a small
outer dimension so if you have a data
structure lower bound this means you
have large outer dimension and this also
implies a circuit lower bound
[Applause]
then the linear transformation given by
it has I so okay first of all were proof
stronger statement here business has a
like I think seems simple proof which I
wanted to present will prove a stronger
statement we don't lose anything
anywhere and we prove it in two
directions so we actually said that
matrix is strongly rigid if and only if
this holds I don't know how to I don't
know how to construct a circuit from
this for example it's I don't think it's
known that any non rigid matrix can be
computed by circuit right so I don't
think this is exactly like the other
direction of variant but we have
equivalence here matrix is stronger if
I'm sure yeah this correspondence does
hold but again here the same as in
circuit law bonds we are talking about
yeah this holds but we know this bounds
in data structure of answers well you
can always take like algebraically
independent elements and say you cannot
compute anything yep do you know
anything what the bike versus log in
fact so I just showed you the worst case
parameters we don't always have this log
n we only for some setting of parameters
but where we do have it no we don't know
how to improve it
the other question okay let's
[Applause]